alors ça ne s'arrête plus après
l'annulation de jean dujardin au jt de
tf1 qui ne voulait plus faire la promo
pour le film j'accuse de roman polanski
qui sort en salles aujourd'hui
il ya désormais tous les autres acteurs
du film qui refusent d'aller dans les
médias du coup petit rappel des faits
dans un petit magnéto
voilà si vous n'étiez pas les hier
ensuite on vous dira tout ce qui s'est
passé depuis et c'est vrai que là ça
tombe alors j'ai que je serais curieux
de savoir comment on va marcher la vraie
vie c'est une bonne promo en fait ou si
c'est une mauvaise propos ce parti
dimanche soir dernier alors que jean
dujardin avait été annoncé comme invité
spécial du 20 heures de tf1 à l'occasion
de la promotion de j'accuse dans lequel
il joue les téléspectateurs d'anne
claire coudray n'ont finalement jamais
eu la chance de voir le comédien en
plateau la raison le réalisateur du film
roman polanski a été une nouvelle fois
accusé de viol par une jeune femme 48
heures plus tôt s'il nie cette agression
sexuelle elle serait de toute façon
prescrite puisqu'elle remonte rey à 1975
une accusation qui fait suite à
plusieurs affaires similaires qui
entache déjà la réputation du cinéaste
face à ses révélations jean dujardin a
décidé de renoncer à sa fiche et pour
les derniers jours de promotion du film
aujourd'hui d'autres stars ont décidé de
suivre la même route
[Musique]
vous avez vu alors donc tout le monde
annuler qu'est ce que vous en pensez ce
que vous comprenez les médias aussi qui
annule la présence des acteurs voilà
c'est les deux mathieu alors d'abord je
comprends évidemment plus aucun bus
aucun acteur né dedans je comprends
qu'on les invite plus on a repassé aussi
aujourd'hui des images elkabbach qui lui
parlaient ils disaient qu'ils disaient
oui j'aime bien les petites ans les
jeunes filles de 14 ans et il disait à
l'époque cnv interview le sexe avec
quelqu'un de 14 ans n'est pas quelque
chose de mal c'est hallucinant de dire
ça en revanche qui moi m'a beaucoup
choqué c'est que la patronne de france
inter ce matin je sais pas si son
partenaire s'ils sont pas ils sont
partenaires mais si tu as besoin du film
c'est le service public a dit écoutez
faisons la part des choses et aller voir
le film qui est très beau pardon encore
une fois on ne sépare pas les gens de
leur oeuvre a fait marcher non je suis
désolé tu peux pas dire quelqu'un a
violé quelqu'un veston film est
magnifique allée le voir
non je suis désolé alors le rêve du prix
alors il pose la vraie question
nationaux moyens dario au téléspectateur
est ce que vous pensez qu'on peut
voilà allez voir le film de roman
polanski mais malgré tout vous est donc
donné de l'argent au non dit nous et moi
je veux la même façon on va pas voir
bertrand compte à sa chaude même si ça
revient alors ça serait qu'il a il a tué
ben c'est pareil
non mais l'église doit pas y arriver il
a raison de l'afrique il est d'accord
avec matthieu delormeau kelly moi la
question parce que tu as tu applaudis
pas polanski ta peau de tête approchent
archie garde un film c'est pas bertrand
cantat sur scène c'est comme quand le
quand tu lis ces lignes
pardon céline était un abject en titre
justin séverine mais tu appelles céline
compliqué bon alors que raymond que ce
soit pour un mois il en liberté ce mec
là pas de quoi la mise en liberté de son
fils en fuite
alors on va le chercher on l'arrête on
arrête la mascarade de laisser faire des
films d'accord parce que là s'il a fait
quelque chose de grave on va chercher
quoi qu'il arrive interpol palais
cherche à qui le commissariat du 12ème
vous avez chez nous
generix a rien sur et je m'en fous il a
fait quelque chose et on arrête ou alors
il fait des films et à ce moment là les
acteurs qui sont dans le film quand il
les a appelés pour leur dire on fait le
film tu vas toucher tant ils ont dit oui
maintenant il faut aller à la promo
c'est faux pas dire non car un césar ils
vont pas aller chercher le sésame
bien sûr qu'ils vont les gérants non
c'est pas une honte tu fais un film avec
un mec tu savais très bien ce qu'il a
fait depuis 2009
on savait ce qu'il a annoncé vainqueur
une ville est en fuite depuis 2009 s'ils
décident d'aller faire un film avec ni
tu sais où tu mets les pieds je suis pas
là pour moi tu fais l'homme s'est passé
facile de dire j'y vais plus non faut y
aller maintenant
ou alors on arrête ce mec là ces
technologies
le parallèle avec quant à sa marche pas
mais ces sujets là on a la liberté
d'aller le voir ou pas il a la liberté
d'aller voir ce film ou pas mais la
promotion devrait se dérouler dans des
conditions normales et que chacun en
connaissance de cause en conscience
décide d'y aller ou pas assez là on
décide pour nous un seul il ya quelque
chose qui va pas ou alors ce type n'a
pas le droit de faire des films où il a
le droit de faire des films là mais si
le droit de faire des films il a droit
aussi de faire la promo il ya un truc
qui va pas là on règle ça entre nous il
n'y a pas de plaintes en plus ya pas de
plainte est d'accord mais c'est quand
même un peu bizarre mais on règle ça en
dehors de la justice magath le problème
au niveau de la promo c'est que la
question sur la culpabilité sur ces
affaires de viol d'agression sexuelle
dont est victime
romane polanski est inévitable donc ça
veut dire que l'émission qui accepte de
recevoir un acteur de ce film si elle ne
pose pas la question si elle élude
complètement le sujet on va lui dire
[ __ ] c'est abusé vous recevez les
acteurs de si vous ne posez même pas
laquelle on a relancé plusieurs fois sur
twitter par exemple bill winters que
j'aime c'est pour ça que les médias se
défausser de la même façon l'acteur qui
vient lui défendre un film une oeuvre un
travail c'est impossible qu'on ne lui
pose pas la question est donc les
accusations dont est victime le roman
polanski qu'en pensez vous isabelle
raymond tu dis il savait inconscience
quand ils ont signé non il ya une
évolution de la situation c'est pour ça
que me laisserais aujourd'hui n'était
pas vrai hier en tout cas pas aussi vrai
tellement pas position de tous est
intenable quand tu reçois dans une
émission tu ne peux pas ne pas poser la
question c'est ce qu'on disait hier or
c'est pas le sujet du film elle mangani
qui va c'est qu'on va lui poser la
question il alimenta si on te dit qu'un
mec qui est accusé pour viol par mentale
te dis je vais pas tourner avec ce film
avec ce mec là quelles que soient nos
acquis va me poser sur la table je vais
pas si tu y vas tu vas jusqu'au 8 avril
sa peine
ce n'était pas si clair que ça à
l'arrivée les dames et la voilà fabien
lecoeuvre
non je pense qu'il ya un vrai problème
d'état c'est plus grave qu'un film qu'un
public un remplissage de salle c'est le
problème des femmes qui ont été
agressées sexuellement il ya plus de 33
ans c'est de savoir est-ce qu'ils sont
les bourreaux sont peuvent être
poursuivis après trente trois ans parce
que c'est quand même le vrai débat
autour de ce vrai c'est le vrai vrai
débat et je pense que les femmes les
associations féministes ont raison
d'insister un moment donné par la presse
à situer la prescription d'innocence en
tout cas je pense que c'est le vrai
débat de la société en 2019 et c est le
procès qu'on fait en ce moment à
polanski
c'est juste ça quand même on sait pas on
se situe parce que finalement c'est un
grand cinéaste c'est un homme il il est
poursuivi il est condamné il s'enfuit
d'un pays pas mais le vrai problème posé
la question est ce qu'on sait que si
vous allez voir le film de romain
zaleski et dissociées l'artiste de
l'homme
mais pardon mais fabien et eric autant
intelligente peut dire autant de bêtises
là vous dites n'importe quoi on n'est
pas en train de juger il ya trente trois
ans et à 30 ans ou est-ce qu'il faut pas
et je suis la corne affaire était pas si
clair las il ya quelques jours il ya une
affaire qui a ressorti la hyène plane
qui ressorti non on parle de ce qui n'a
pas bien compris
laban en trois ans de retard et non 20
n'ont toujours pas faire de ces savants
musulmans mais qui ressort là oui mais
il ya surtout de delhaize comme sur
gazeille appréciation oui c'est la
raison pour laquelle ne dépose pas
plainte malheureusement c'est ça c'est
ça le problème ce toit l'arrivée à meaux
jour d'hui toutes les femmes qui sont
agressés et un moment donné ça peut se
comprendre et je pense que tu peux quand
même un peu le comprendre c'est que
c'est un vrai problème parce que cette
visite à 34 ans il peut pas être
poursuivi il ya un problème de justice
pour être précis et ça fait très
longtemps qui a été condamné à une peine
de prison 80 des thons en amérique donc
le débat il n'est pas d'aujourd'hui donc
c'est pas maintenant qu'il faut se poser
la question il a fait des tas de films
il est des césars il a fait s est fait
des chefs d'oeuvre soit il fallait quand
il fallait pas le produire il reste tant
qu'il est là c'est pas aux comédiens
d'aller défendre ce monsieur mais voilà
c'est ça le problème à l'arrêt plein
moi j'aime le cinéma et je vais céder
vérité qui va les voir jouer à l'avant
ce qui devrait pourtant voir donc il
vous donnait quatre personnes qui vont
aller voir c'est ça fait ça c'est déjà
beaucoup et vous paie rien
oui à 54% non à 46 ans elle fut lu le
roman polanski oui mais 64%